I think your prediction was by the end
of 2018 you think Bitcoin is gonna hit
78,000 live that I didn't make it 28
there 2018 projection I made a 20/20
protection I think he said 78,000 to
somebody for 2018 I remember seeing
78,000 if I'm wrong you may have seen
that then it may have been written but I
promise you I did not say that quite a
few people said 40 $50,000 you're
probably even higher than that in your
estimation if it's going to get to a
million by 2020 they're saying 40
$50,000 by the end of 2018 is what many
people are expecting that's now no my my
figures at 78,000 by the end of 2018 yes
so are you familiar with Jordan Bell for
the guy the wolf of Wall Street yeah of
course I interviewed him I was at his
place and we were sitting out talking
about Bitcoin and I said tell me what
you think about Bitcoin and what's gonna
happen he said here's the thing when
this thing really goes if it's at 30,000
it's not working with 30,000 to 29,000
to 28 is it over 30,000 to 1 you have a
complete different perspective on
Bitcoin because the way they describe it
tell me your point of view on Bitcoin
why you think bitcoin is going to go to
million dollars by 2020
joy's to do it the most common way is to
take the number of users a Bitcoin
because as Bitcoin expands and its user
base both people who who hold the coin
and people who accept the coin for
payment its skyrocketing its
skyrocketing so it's not going to
disappear it can't possibly go to zero
it can only grow as the user base grows
so it's impossible Belfort thought of
how smart he is he's wrong he does not
understand digital currencies and how
they work
listen it's it's Pandora's box the box
has been open the spirits are invading
the room and they will not go back in
and you have to believe me
digital currencies will replace fiat
currencies why good God I have a wallet
on my phone which is an entire bank
lending money sending wires I don't have
to go to the bank it takes me 10 seconds
to do a wire Tim I've got to go down to
the bank fill out a bunch of forms no
that's nonsense
other than nonsense do you think that is
gonna go to zero the part that concerns
me with Bitcoin I I really want to hear
your rebuttal on this when Jamie diamond
is touching 7 trillion dollars of money
per day of transactions that's not just
money that's a lot of political power
but a lot of countries that are
connected to that 7 trillion dollars yes
and so he is one phone call away from so
many different Prime Minister's
presidents kings sheiks whatever you
want to call it because my he's touching
all these mom and I'm not talking small
money we're talking big money or you
know what i'ma destroy seven trillion
there's a lot of money okay so half of
our gross domestic product
if it goes in the direction of these 21
million
you know bitcoins being used and four
millions lost I think I don't know the
number that was lost I think it's four
million of them that was lost some
number like that don't you think a guy
like that and these guys who control
elections and control all these other
things don't you think they're gonna
make a phone call and you know they're
gonna say hey listen mr. congressman mr.
senator you want to do this again
don't make sure you take care of this
think you you cannot let this Bitcoin
stuff take off the way that this is out
of control already don't you think
they're gonna make those calls to figure
out a way to do what they've always done
which is listen small business owner
wants to compete with the big business
owner how do you beat them very simple
big business owner goes to somebody and
helps them uh financially in a political
side and says listen make the barriers
to enter more difficult how do you do it
more regulations more licensing more
laws more rules more this stuff and so
the new guy cannot come and compete with
this guy he has in a sense a monopoly
with two other companies if you want to
call her monopoly so that is my only
concern with a the argument you're
making is but you're assuming that
Congress might whatever laws they want
obviously they can outlaw Bitcoin they
can about go on you're assuming that
there is a possibility of enforcing
those laws that's utter [ __ ] nonsense
you cannot stop a distributed system
that is worldwide there is no law that
you can make if you had one person per
were per citizen in the country 400
million enforcers you still couldn't do
it well because you unfortunately have
to sleep for some at some point it's not
possible okay no admittedly the way the
things were six months ago when does
when
exchanges were centralized he could shut
down in exchange you can't do that
anymore
they've now decentralized exchanges you
can't stop it you can't shut it down and
you can't know anything about it
so tell me sir how will you enforce
these magical laws that Congress is
gonna make Jamie demon has no power in
this world but here's the misconception
the misconception is that legislation
can have teeth it's not possible this is
a distributed world there is no
legislation that can touch it you can't
change it you can't fix it you can't
stop it you can't control it you can't
direct it you have no power I don't make
the laws
so Mike whatever you want it will make
no difference you are that's certain
about it well I'm a technologist for
God's sake we're talking technology a
lot of technology people have been wrong
in the past before though but you're
that's not wrong without their
technology this is technology I'm
telling you something just like I can
tell you anti-virus software does not
work because it cannot stop the hackers
in the world I'd say I said that earlier
why because it technologically can't
nothing can know
same thing with Bitcoin you can't stop
Bitcoin this is a fact technologically
impossible